-I haven't been able to
congratulate you
on winning your Academy Award
for "Judy," by the way.
[ Cheers and applause ]
You were unbelievable
playing Judy Garland.
You were phenomenal
in that as well.
What do you remember about
winning the Oscar?
Do you get excited for
these awards?
-You know -- Well, yeah.
I mean, of course, it's kind of
like you think
it's a once-in-a-lifetime
experience.
You want to pay attention and I
always try to, you know --
I want to be grounded
when I go in.
I just want to get in touch with
my family,
talk to my mom, dad, my brother.
-That's good.
-Do things that keep you
grounded before you go into it.
-Don't get too big-headed
going in.
-You know, keep your feet
on the ground
and just kind of enjoy
the moment.
So I have a couple rituals
and things that I like to do
before I go -- I like to walk.
I don't like to get in the car,
you know, the long limo ride.
-So you don't take
a limousine there?
-Unh-unh, no, no, no,
'cause I don't like getting out
and it's all crazy
and people screaming and stuff.
So I sneak in.
[ Laughter ]
-You walk to the Oscars?
-I walk to the Oscars.
-That's the greatest thing
I ever heard.
-I sneak in, 'cause you know
all the people come out,
and they stand and they're
looking at the red carpet,
so I come in
behind all the people.
[ Laughter ]
-Wow!
-Yeah, I sneak in behind
all those -- So, this time,
the only hotel room
that was available
was a half a mile away.
[ Laughter ]
-You walked a half a mile
to the Oscars?
-I did.
In shoes taller than this.
And I don't recommend it.
But it is a good exercise
for keeping you grounded.
[ Laughter ]
-Oh, my God.
You're like, "Why did I start
this tradition?"
-Yeah, and it was raining
that night,
so I was extra grounded
when I got there.
-Oh, my gosh.
You were really grounded.
-The girls know what
I'm talking about.
You know, you do your hair
and then you're like, "Ohh."
[ Laughter ]
-Did you get to party
afterwards?
-Do you know what? Yeah, I did.
I went back to the hotel and had
a little private dance party
with my really good friends who
filled the room with balloons,
and we ordered cheeseburgers,
as you do.
And then we went to my pal
Guy Oseary's house.
I've known him for --
You know Guy, right?
-I love Guy Oseary.
-Guy Oseary, yeah.
He's a music manager,
but when I met him,
he was 17 years old and he was
interning at Maverick.
-Yes.
-And every year now he hosts
this after party that,
if you can believe it,
begins at 1:00 in the morning.
And you take your shoes off,
and nobody takes pictures.
And he just turns the music up
the really loudly,
and you just dance
in the living room.
-That's exactly how you do it.
-Yeah, right?
-That's what you're supposed
to do and have fun.
-In that dress. Yeah, no shoes.
Every year he does
something fun.
One year, he had this photo
booth that you go into,
and it takes pictures,
and then you get this book.
It's kind of like an animation
where you flip it --
the flip book, you know?
-Yeah.
-Yeah, so you make this flip
book from the photographs.
And last year he had
this photographer --
or two years ago now,
my goodness --
he had a photographer named J.R.
He takes a picture of you,
then he takes a picture of you
with the picture --
life-size picture.
Really cool. The cooler part
was, though,
that Snoop Dogg was in the back.
[ Laughter ]
-It's always a fun party
when Snoop Dogg's there, yeah.
-It's fun when Snoop Dogg's
anywhere.
-Yeah, exactly. I agree.
-Yeah, so, he asked if we could
take a picture together.
Come on!
-You brought it to show tonight.
Here's you and Snoop Dogg.
Look at -- Not too shabby.
I like that.
-Come on!
[ Cheers and applause ]
-I would go see that movie.
-Come on!
-I would watch this movie.
-Right?
-Yeah.
-I mean, right?
So, you go, you're like,
"It's Oscar night,"
but then it's, like, Snoop Dogg.
-Yeah, that was a Snoop Dogg
night.
-A great night.
It was a great night.
-Did you stay grounded
when you were also nominated
for a Grammy Award, by the way,
pal?
Congratulations!
-Oh, that was crazy.
-I mean, come on.
-Thanks. Thank you.
-Did you ever imagine in your
life, you go, "Oh, my gosh."
-No, not a chance.
You know, not a chance.
Yeah, no, no, no.
And with Harry Connick,
my buddy.
And Rufus Wainwright,
who we actually did a duet.
We did "Have Yourself
a Merry Little Christmas"
on the "Judy" record.
-You must have seen when Rufus
did "Rufus! Rufus! Rufus!"
That concert?
-Oh, come on, I mean.
-No, exactly, of course,
I mean, yeah.
-He's extraordinary.
-It was his tribute
to "Judy, Judy, Judy,"
and who you just knocked it
out of the park with.
-Thanks, Jimmy.
-But do you get intimidated when
you get in there with
Rufus Wainwright to sing?
-Oh, gosh, yeah, you just got to
pretend really hard
that you're doing okay,
you know?
-Yeah, I guess that's what
acting is. Yeah, I guess.
-Yeah, some of the best
performances in life
happen behind the scenes.
-Yeah.
-No, that was really emotional
for me 'cause I have loved him.
I mean, I've been singing duets
with him for 20 years
in Laurel Canyon, in my car.
-Yes, on the speakers, yeah.
In real life, you're like,
"Oh, my gosh."
-Yeah, it was a big deal.
Big deal for me.
-We're all excited here,
not just because it's NBC,
but it is NBC tomorrow at 10:00
p.m., "The Thing About Pam."
It is getting crazy-good
reviews, crazy-good buzz.
One reporter was like, "Just
give her the Emmy right now.
If this world has any sense to
it, please just give it to her.
Renée Zellweger knocks it
out of the park."
"The Thing About Pam" --
I love true crime.
My wife loves true crime.
We watch "Dateline."
I try to make sure I don't watch
it right before I go to bed.
-Right, right, right.
[ Laughter ]
But inevitably, you do.
-You do.
You do, and I have
pretty awesome nightmares.
[ Laughter ]
But I didn't know about
this podcast.
-Mm-hmm.
-When you first heard --
You got attached
when it was just a podcast?
-Yeah, yeah, it was one of
the most popular "Dateline"
episodes ever.
I missed that one.
But then, my partner,
Carmella Casinelli,
at the Big Picture Co.,
sent me the podcast.
And I listened to it
on the 5 freeway when I was
taking Chester,
the rescue shepherd,
up to get his hip replaced.
-Aww.
-Yeah, and that was between the
Golden Globes and the Oscars.
-Really keeping you grounded.
-It's the best.
-How's Chester? Is he okay?
-He's rocking.
Yeah, he's got his bionic hip,
and he's so cool.
-That's awesome.
-He's so cool.
But, yeah, so, I listened to it.
I binged it.
And I thought,
"Man, that's so crazy."
You just got started asking
yourself, "How, how, how?"
There's so much evidence
pointing away from
this woman's husband, who was
actually convicted of murder.
It's based on -- Well,
the podcast revolves around
the story of Betsy Faria,
the case of Betsy Faria's murder
in 2011.
And her husband was convicted
and later exonerated.
-And you play Pam?
-I play Betsy's friend, Pam,
Pam Hupp, mm-hmm.
-Yeah, and you go, "Yeah."
And then you go,
"It's the husband."
It's like all these great true
crimes where you're like,
"Oh, the husband did it."
-Yeah, "he did it." Yeah.
-It's insurance,
that's what it is.
Though what's even amazing?
You got Keith Morrison from
"Dateline" to narrate the show.
Double whammy.
I'm like, "What?!"
Any super nerd is going to
freak out,
'cause I love Keith Morrison.
-Love Keith Morrison.
-Once I hear his voice I go,
"Oh, my God. No, no, no."
-See, that's the fun thing.
You start sitting there,
you're like, "Hmm, I'm going to
call Rufus Wainwright."
-No, yeah, you get
Keith Morrison, why not?
But you are unrecognizable
in this.
You have an accent --
a Missouri accent?
-Yeah, a little bit, yeah.
It's sort of ephemeral because
she moved around a lot.
It was very specific to her,
so, you know --
-And you had crazy prosthetics,
amazing job.
Who did the prosthetics?
-His name is Arian Titan, yeah.
Arian -- he's a genius.
He does the cast,
and then he hand-paints everyone
down to the last freckle.
-And how long are you
in prosthetic for?
-Well, we started at about
4 hours and 20 or 30 minutes,
and he whittled it down
to under 3, like 2 1/2,
by the time, you know, you get
in the swing of things.
-Just four hours just getting
into makeup?
-Yeah, yeah, yeah.
-Then you have to act?
-Yeah.
-No, no, no.
[ Laughter ]
That's why you do what you do.
-No, it's great.
You can call your mom
in the chair,
you get your e-mails done,
Christmas shopping.
[ Laughter ]
-You got it all done, yeah.
Is there a learning curve
to acting in prosthetics?
-Well, I didn't know that it's
a whole different skill
that I didn't know
I didn't have.
[ Laughter ]
And I really didn't have it.
I really didn't.
By the time you get it on,
you're so excited,
and you stand there
and then you go,
"Oh, wait, I think
I'm allergic to this."
[ Laughter ]
-You were allergic to
prosthetics?
-I was so allergic
to the adhesive.
It was hilarious.
Y'all, lots of Benadryl.
Lots of Benadryl.
[ Laughter ]
-Oh, my God.
Benadryl knocks me out, man.
Oh, my God, no way.
And you still did
that knockout performance?
I want to say more about
"The Thing About Pam,"
but I can't because --
-You can't.
-It's an ongoing --
-So, Jimmy,
it's the weirdest thing.
I get these interviews,
"What interested you about
this story?"
And I'm like,
"Um, nah-nah-nah, mm."
-Yeah, you're like, "Ooh, uh.
Kern. Kern." Exactly.
[ Laughter ]
-No, wait. It's a-a-art.
-Art, yeah.
Art. Yeah.
-You know, 'cause it's
an ongoing case.
And, you know,
it's a real person.
So I'm not allowed to
sort of speculate.
Especially, you know, on
television and stuff like that.
So, you get asked
these questions,
and I start answering it
and then I catch myself
going down the rabbit hole
and I try to correct.
-Yeah, you go, "Don't stop,
just stop talking."
-Yeah, you're watching yourself
talking,
and you're like, "Just shut up.
Just shut your mouth."
-This is so exciting.
I cannot wait for this thing.
I want to show everyone a clip.
Here's Renée Zellweger
in "The Thing About Pam."
Take a look at this.
-That's how come Mariah moved in
with Betsy's mom.
-Was he ever violent with Betsy?
-I was at their place a lot,
and, um, he's not --
he's not the most, um...
He was kind of not nice verbally
to her.
Mm.
You know the type.
Real aggressive.
[ Cheers and applause ]
-Wow!
You know the type.
Renée Zellweger, everybody.
"The Thing About Pam" premieres
tomorrow at 10:00 p.m. on NBC.